نقلت وكاله انترفاكس للانباء عن النائب
الروسي اندريه كارتبو قوله اليوم ان روسيا
واوكرانيا ستواصلان تبادل اسرى الحرب رغم
اسقاط هذه الطائره العسكريه الروسيه
للمزيد حول هذا الملف معي في الاسجين عبد
الله ملكاوي اهلا بك عبد الله اهلا بك عبد
الله روسيا ايضا تتهم اوكرانيا باسقاط
الطائره واوكرانيا تحمل روسيا المسؤوليه
لكن ما هي الروايه
الارجح الطرفان يتبادلان الاتهامات
بالتاكيد يعني لا
يوجد اي روايه راجحه سواء لدى الطرف
الروسي او الاوكراني لكن سنحاول تقديم من
الصعب بالتاكيد
اثبات روايه دون اخرى لكن سنحاول اعطاء
يعني عده عناصر ربما ستساعد في فهم اكثر
لما حدث وربما فيما بعد يعني يكون هناك
معلومات اكثر بدايه من روسيا موسكو اتهمت
اوكرانيا مباشره باسقاط هذه الطائره وقالت
انها اسقطتها بصاروخين من قاعده جويه في
خاركيف التي تبعد عن المكان حوالي
45 كيلومترا وانه كانت تحمل اسرى ومن
المفترض ان يكون هناك تبادل الاسرى لكن
حتى الان روسيا لم تقدم اي ادله حتى انها
لم تطرح اسماء الاسرى هي قالت ان الطائره
كانت تحمل
65 اسيرا اوكرانيا كان يجب ان يجري تجري
عمليه تبادل لكن حتى اللائحه باسماء هؤلاء
الاسر لم تطرح لم تقدم اي ادله ثابته على
ان السلطات الاوكرانيه او القوات
الاوكرانيه هي من استهدفت هذا هذه
الطائره لكنها اليوم اعلنت انها انتشلت
الصندوقين الاسودين للطائره ولكن كما
ذكرنا حتى الان لم تقدم اي معلومات
بالتاكيد هي طلبت بجلسه طارئه في مجلس
الامن ستعقد هذا المساء ب على اساس ان
اوكرانيا قامت بهجمات ارهابيه من
جانبها فقط قناه روسيا اليوم على منصه
تليغرام احدى رئيسات التحرير طرحت لائحه
عليها بعض اسماء الاسرى الذين كانوا على
متن هذه الطائره لكن جاء رد من اطراف
اوكرانيه قالت ان على الاقل احد اسماء
هؤلاء الاسرى وهو ماكسيم كونو
فالينو قد تم اطلاق سراحه مسبقا اي انه ان
هذه اللائحه يعني يتم التشكيك فيها من
جهتها كيف لم تؤكد او تنفي انها اسقطت
الطائره قالت انها ستواصل استهداف
الطائرات العسكريه التي تهدد امنها في هذه
المنطقه وايضا سبق وان استهدفت منطقه
بلغورد بصواريخ و بمسيرات
وا يعني هذا يدع نوع من من الشك ايضا ان
اوكرانيا قد تكون
فعلا يعني اسقطت هذه الطائره وهي قالت
انها لم تكن تعلم بانها تحمل اسرى قالت
انها لم تكن على علم
بان هناك طائره ستسير في هذا المسار تحمل
اسرى لكن الجدير بذكر هو انه كان هناك
اتفاق على عمليه تبادل اسرى في المنطقه
لكن اوكرانيا تنفي انها ك كان لديها علم
عن نقل هؤلاء الاسرى وروسيا تؤكد بانها
اخبرت اوكرانيا بالتاكيد انتشار الصندوقين
ودين قد يعطي المزيد من المعلومات في حين
ان اوكرانيا عندما طالبت بتحقيق دولي هي
تعلم تماما بان روسيا لن تسمح ل يعني
خبراء دوليين بالذهاب الى هناك وتعلم بانه
لن يتم هذا التحقيق الدولي طيب عبد الله
تبعنا ما قاله النائب الروسي اندري كارتا
بولوف حول هذه القضيه الى اي مدى ستؤثر
ستؤثر هذه الحادثه على عمليه تبادل الاسرى
بين
الدولتين بالبدايه يعني النائب او المتحدث
باسم الكرملين بدايه عندما ادلى بتصريحات
حول هذه الحادثه قال انه لا يستطيع تحديد
مدى تاثير هذه الحادثه على عمليه تبادل
الاسرى اي ترك نوع من الشك يعني والغموض
حول هذا الموضوع النائب الروسي اندري
كارتا بولوف قال كما ذكرتي ان هذا لن
يؤثر السؤال هل سيؤثر بالتاكيد سيؤثر
سيؤثر كيف سيؤثر سيؤثر من حيث التعامل مع
الملف ان كان فعلا سقط
65 اسيرا اوكرانيا فهذا يعني سيدفع
اوكرانيا للتعامل مع الملف بخصوصيه وبان
هذا سيصعب من عمليات تبادل الاسرى
بالتاكيد سيكون هناك حاله من الحذر وعدم
الثقه في هذا الملف عندما يتم نقل الاسرى
و لا يتم الاعلان عنهم يتم اسقاط طائره
تحمل اسرى ان تاكد ذلك فهذا يعني
سيخلق حاله من عدم الثقه بين الطرفان
وبالتالي سيصعب من هذه المهمه ذكرا اقول
ان تم تاكيد انها كانت تحمل اسرى ذكرا بان
هناك موقع اوكراني لم يستند لادلا لكنه
اوكرين فورم يسمى قال ان الطائره كانت
تحمل صواريخ دفاعيه صواريخ اس 300 معده
لقصف اوكرانيا بالتاكيد لم يعتمد على اي
مصادر رسميه ولكن هذه المعلومه ذكرت
وبالتالي هذا سيصعب اذا من عمليه تبادل
الاسرى هل ستتوقف عمليه تبادل الاسرى
بالطبع لا بالتاكيد ان الطرفان الطرفين
بحاجه لتبادل الاسرى لان هناك الكثير من
الاسرى من من جهه ومن من الجهه ومن الجهه
الاخرى اوكرانيا تقول ان لديها لدى موسكو
ث 8000 اسير بينهم 1600 مدنيه وبالتالي
بالتاكيد ستستمر عمليات تبادل الاسرى
لحاجه الطرفان طرفين
بهذه مثل هذه العمليات تبادل الاسرى لكن
ستؤثر بالتاكيد ستؤثر وسيكون المزيد من
الحذر وعدم الثقه في هذا الملف اشكرك
زميلي عبد الله على كل هذه
التوضيحات